alors petite polémique quand mais alors
ça marche ça marche bien
la 3008 c'est france 2 qui était leader
lens a pas vraiment profité ont filmé en
noir très bien ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle
alors c'est vrai que l'on s'est posé la
question de savoir si les candidats
finalement au final au demeurant au
final il était pas un peu manipulée en
fait ma on s'est posé la question et on
s'est demandé si ce n'était pas trop
scénarisé regardez on a eu la puce à
l'oreille
cette nouvelle saison de l'amour est
dans le pré est particulièrement
mouvementée départ dérapages lettre de
dernière minute autour de candidats on
se croirait devant un véritable téléfilm
américain
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui commence à
faire tiquer certains téléspectateurs
contrairement aux autres saisons cette
fois-ci l'émission ressemble plus à un
jeu scénarisé qu'à une émission de
dating karine le marchand elle aussi
intervient beaucoup plus dans les
relations directes des agriculteurs
comme lors de ce rabibochage entre eric
le chevrier et claudine t'avais fonder
des espoirs dans cette histoire fait la
paix réfléchis et rep a retenti qu'à une
intervention qui a mené pour la toute
première fois de l'histoire du jeu à la
modification des règles
une façon de créer des rebondissements
pour la première fois dans l'amour est
dans le pré une nouvelle chance s'offre
à un agriculteur avec une lettre de
toutes dernières minutes des épisodes
qui semble beaucoup plus scripté que
d'habitude et une saison qui semble
manquer de naturel jamais m clip gros
sur la patate
alors l'amour est dans le pré sur m6 les
candidats sont ils manipulés
les candidats sont des manipulés alors
pour moi ou ça mais c'est pas un secret
je suis pas fan du taux d'émission mais
mais c'est vrai qu'avant il y avait une
petite petite fraîcheur
là on a senti books et voilà que c'est
un peu voilà c'est devenu un vrai dating
kevin oui bien sûr c'est scénarisé de
toute façon on sait que lors du montage
à ce qu'on appelle une bible il faudra
compter les lisible eu une bimbo faut
dire qu'il faut raconter des histoires
[Rires]
racontées une histoire il faut faire un
montage il faut fidéliser
téléspectateurs donc oui bien évidemment
ils sont manipulés manipuler c'est un
grand nom mais on les dirige
pour les défendre j'ai toujours parce
que j'étais toujours ça et magali va me
soutenir aux candidates et les athées
qui se plaignent que les cours montent
deux mais pas vraiment eu les images
elles sont là oui on peut leur murmurait
à l'oreille du cheval oui mais les
chauffeurs mois pointe dans une émission
de dating donc c'est une émission de
télé réalité très un saison qui
s'appelle comment les princes de l'amour
sur w9 avec le petit castaldi l'a
bientôt mais du coup je connais bien le
le principe
alors non c'est pas scénarisée un peu
parce que non c'est pas s'énerver parce
qu'en fait quand les candidats arrivent
on les laisse vivre on les laisse
totalement ivre et il se passe des
choses à l'intérieur des maisons ou des
sites des situations et ensuite par
rapport à ce qui se passe effectivement
la preuve bas va agir et bat organiser
quelque chose pour faire vivre
l'histoire mais que les candidats ont
créé voyez ce que je dis moi la maison
donc oui mais bon sait jamais dit non
non tu les dirigeants n'ont fait une en
tue les dirigeants font suite à thé en
fonction il ya les gars ont fait un come
back d'un candidat qui s'est fait sortir
quelque part vous transgressez un peu la
règle
c'est une histoire six ans comme moi
j'ai eu par exemple dans cette saison
vous verrez j'ai pas le droit de le dire
quoi mais il ya des combats qui se font
parce qu'il ya une histoire à
l'intérieur de la maison et parce que
bahia quelque chose qui fait que la
personne doit revenir c'est aussi de là
c'est vrai que nous sur le loft sur
secret' quand on voulait pas perdre un
candidat ont posé une question méritent
ils vraiment deux parties harry
oui nicolas s'est pas exprimée c'est pas
manipuler un pas du tout non je pense
que effectivement c'est fictionné parce
que il ya des fois où il se passe rien
donc il faut bien y faire quelque chose
autour mais quand vous regardez par
exemple le candidat qu'on vient de voir
moi je suis dans l'amour est dans le pré
j'aime dire comment mais vous regardez
une cas d'éric et claudine franchement
s'ils étaient manipulés déjà il l'aurait
jamais laissée recevoir claudine dans
l'état dans lequel renault était quand
même ses 120 kg ils ont été reconnus
comme étant des dîners de on va le lui
voilà là est plutôt sympa mais c'est il
est né quand même très animal mais il
est torse nu quand il reçoit colline
pendant le dîner regardent la télévision
s'ils étaient manipulés en auront donné
un peu plus un petit peu plus entre le
masne ll part parce qu'elle n'aurait
c'est à dire que il dit clairement
qu'entre elle et la télé le choix est
fait et la télé bon en france rémy sur
un homme lucide je rigole
j'adore cette émission met donc tu me
disais tu voulais me oui je voulais
parler après bossue ça tombe bien c'est
à dire les choses honnêtement pas ce que
tu mérites pas que enfin d'attendre plus
longtemps et tout ça j'apprécie beaucoup
mais en tant qu'ami si jamais demain je
te dis tu continues l' aventure
eh ben
je suis très à l'aise à ses côtés sauf
que j'étais pas en fait le coeur qui si
elle est lente pour m'engager en fait
bon il n'y a pas eu cette étincelle on
va on va regarder quand même là
me l'amour est dans le pré alors mangez
bien sûr avec la réaction forcément il
et les maîtrise c'est plus triste est
que tant que le mec qui n'a vu une nana
2 minutes 30
et elle s'en va il est en larmes se
marie jeanne et bien je vous le dis à
regarder
porte toi bien merci pour tout
[Musique]
je ne retiens que parce que pour tous je
peux pas
vous saviez
oh là dessus
[Musique]
mais bon
c'est la vie
ce prénom qu'il est passé je suis resté
sur sur le quai le prochain sera le
mieux
[Musique]
la page avait lui dire qu'ils se
consolent vite parce qu'il n'a pas eu à
payer dans son inventaire penser qu'il
peut être manipulable par exemple
sérieusement oui bien sûr pas mais pas
du tout c'est le coeur qui parle
concrètes pardon c'est que pendant mon
tournage donc une émission dating sur le
même groupe
donc c'est relativement les mêmes
fonctions de faire un peu au tournage
vous n'êtes pas avec des acteurs non
mais c'est une émission de dating c'est
pareil sur les mêmes chaînes baltes
moment où je peux nous donner leurs noms
non non j'ai derrière moi mais on
n'avait pas les dés roulent était moi
j'ai animé le programme et j'avais aussi
la chance avait un rôle à l'intérêt du
programme mois la production de me
donner ce que j'allais faire quand
tournage que le matin même voir la
veille au soir parce qu'on attendait de
savoir ce qui allait se passer à
l'intérieur du programme par rapport aux
candidats
donc c'est pas scénarisée du tout
puisque je savais pas ce que j'allais
faire jusqu'au jour même en fait donc
c'était très intense parce que toutes
les choses avant un nouveau truc à faire
j'ai passé leur vaut des éléments au
fait c'est bon vous adorez ce programme
évident avoue le déguster avec des
chocolats
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est un
peu moi au masculin c'est à dire ça fait
30 ans qu'il n'a pas vu de femmes chez
lui il en a deux et il se prend deux
râteaux imaginer c'est comme si j'invite
bayou et nicolas pernikoff et je me
prends dorada vous allez branche de
râteaux mais alors si c'est maman qui
n'est pas même manipulé comment
voulez-vous mais ce serait le meilleur
comédien de la terre si pleurait sur le
monde il est beau mais en revanche c'est
évidemment qu'il ya des rebondissements
salle à l'émission elle seule elle se
sent là serait autrement
là ils vont lui ont trouvé une nouvelle
prétendante à erie qui lui donne une
seconde chance
il change les règles mais on s'en fiche
si c'est pour le bien des candidats
et si nous ça nous fait des rebonds 10
le bien de l'émission range qui alors
j'ai demandé à faire passer l'arrêter
après gérad rires oui oui j p ben moi
pour moi on s'est préparé mon je vois il
peut très bien jouer le jeu c'est pas
parce que c'est vrai qu'il est touchant
mais il peut être très fort regardons il
avait l'air malheureux là non moi je
suis pas fan
après je veux dire si le mec qui galère
aussi à avoir quelqu'un je comprends
qu'il ait les moules et qui fonde tous
ses espoirs sur quelques heures mais moi
je reste persuadé qu'on peut orienter et
guider un peu comme elle le fait moi
j'aime pas ce programme 1 mais comme
quand elle les guide en disant oui fais
ci fais ça les gens se laissent guider
ils vont dans le sens de la production
avec eux aussi mettre deux prétendants
dont tu sais pertinemment qu'elles vont
jamais rester avec le avec avec le gars
est plus que tu écris l'histoire à
l'avancé c'est lui qui les choisit à
bria oui et non il ya une chose que vous
avez oublié qui est toute simple c'est
qu'ils peuvent être manipulées
involontairement ces gens là ils ont
jamais fait de télé et la pétition il y
un sari c est donc au lieu qui n'est pas
justement enfin il qui se passe rien
donc on va les orienter en valeur
est ce que vous pouvez faire ceci la
manip et ancien donc ils sont manipulés
mais involontairement c'est juste pour
qu'il se passe quelque chose parce que
ces gens là ils ne savent pas quoi faire
donc moi je dis oui et non alors
justement encore il ya eu une
déclaration qui est fait par un ancien
candidat en 2012
une première accusation été fait contre
la production par dany un ancien
candidat qui leur reprochaient leur fait
signer une clause importante en imposant
le silence ainsi qu'une célébration
forcé de certaines scènes à il avait
abus et notamment sa voiture et la prod
avait demandé à dany d'accuser une de
ses prétendantes ce qu'il n'aurait ce
qu'il aurait fait d'ailleurs donc c'est
grave ça c est pas bien la preuve qu'il
ya des interventions dans le programme c
est ce qu il a sorti le contrat est
est-ce qu'il assortit cette clause ça le
problème le promu clauses du closeau de
hockey c'est ce que si on la sort on se
fait si le dit et que ça bouge c'est
qu'ils balancent l'action parce que
c'est trop facile d'aller faire des
polémiques sans aucune preuve et je lui
ai dit ce que j'ai envie et bizarrement
ce qu'ils font ça et vous remarquerez ce
que je dis c'est que c'est toujours ceux
qui ont tourné il ya dix ans en fait ils
n'ont plus d'actualité et qui viennent
maintenant ou qui sont plus repris dans
un programme qui viennent pour démonter
la production vous savez après magali je
vais te doit parapher et benji va être
d'accord avec moi je ne sais pas
sûrement le savons mais là la télé reste
aussi de la télé c'est du divertissement
il n'y a pas de place au hasard à la
télé mais je te comprends pas d'accord
donc il ya des choses comme il l'a très
bien dit on peut peut-être orienter un
candidat sans qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
ont lorsqu'ils vous répond très
clairement la télé réalité très simple
la production à un moyen très simple de
faire ce qu'il veut c'est que soit il
veut le rendre sympathique une personne
soit il veut pas lancer ses préfaces et
puis des sas a eu depuis maintenant il
va bien tant qu'armée tessa directement
que vous voulez maintenant ce que font
les gens d'un programme ça reste qu'ils
ont dit après moi ce ce garçon lâche ne
voulons totalement antipathique avec un
montage il n'est pas à son avantage
donc ça c'est vrai c'est simple on joue
c'est vrai après ça lors de
manipulations plus tard prod qui
manipulent mais alors insultes parce que
je pense pas qu'il leur parle des règles
qui n'ont rien